hello and welcome to this video playing
sonic director wise hmm probably not
pronouncing this in any way correctly
we'll see ok let's decline the Benoni
and go for some English opening the
Benoni guys quite often have some issues
with those positions that seem Bishop
before and slightly questionable in this
some this precise online knight on c6
let that all doesn't work too well
together the dark squares on in the
issue if he decides to take ya Bishop f4
is an interesting set up in this some
type of position kun to a 5 Wow where
are you going with this there ok well
I'm happy to play c5 and now I can put a
bishop on the six or i can play Knight
to f4 which is also interesting yeah
let's do this
Jack unit 526 wasn't was it a very
successful operation hmm okay now
probably here it's hard to say even
Bishop b2 is not completely completely
wrong let's win the peace age 6 bottom
hmm decision but I think the position
was was already lost anyway
strategically I mean um okay so what now
maybe p for threatening Knight c3
winning the Queen it's not so easy to
yeah so let's do this
okie dokie okay let's let's have a look
there let's go maybe here's a bit safer
yeah it shouldn't allow them made on g2
jaz there anyway to make him resign this
game probably not
okay some between age 5 or Luke's is six
ok starting with Roxy six pushes the
Queen back to d8 you cannot take you to
97 and then create 5 i'm probably
getting an attack myself this is also no
it's not losing the queen but i have
rookie 7 it's not bad
yeah don't tell me now you're letting
the clock run down that's come on don't
waste all allows time okay so i can take
the queen but that's probably just BAM
it takes you take you one so he will get
two looks for it this is a lot easier
okay so night is seven is a possibility
than 25 Jim
between h5 there is Bishop chief form
but it's also doesn't matter much and
still do it
here to simplify reading made on g7 he
cannot take the night one be three and
the queen is attacked it's a bit awkward
checkmate yea the dead opening has
already Bishop before as belief to be
slightly inaccurate him it's a little
bit the problem is a bit if we look at
this position that black doesn't have a
a good movie on unfortunately he wants
to somehow develop that bishop but how
is he going to do it if he moves the
deep horn-like d5 for example here then
i will take and the resulting position
is some yeah that's like a taraji Queens
gambit where the bishop is just wrong
for example after Misha black bush and
move like Bishop g5 or even even
something like this and look see one let
Bishop is just misplaced here it has two
should be only seven or f8 or something
the other issue is that sometimes white
can also play in this way and also it
can be awkward black never wants to take
on c3 and said we can see dark squares
enormously yeah a six is hmm yeah it's a
bit of a non move it doesn't help at all
and pusher there for now maybe g5 and
this is already questionable because you
don't have a good square for the Queen I
was expecting this and here it's an
interesting question if I want to go
lucky for or if I want to play something
like this this is the simple
continuation but not bad at all
something like this it's better white
but this also comes in you can consider
comes into consideration if black takes
this is a very awkward position why does
it look better develop and look at this
yeah that's really bad yeah this is
universe though after c5 that's I think
this is close to win already it's very
bad black doesn't get the beardy points
moving yeah e5 here and yeah h6 is
losing now I mean like losing material
he has to play something else d 6 on
some awkward move yeah this this and
loses a piece you could have done that
maybe to avoid the piece loss but this
is also also remarkable yes I'm gonna
make this yeah it does this black can
safely resign a funny position the end
here goes he just was the piece down
probably I could have one day to go it I
think it was it was reasonably
reasonably convincing yeah that's not a
good opening line and it was punished in
this game okay thanks for watching